bonsoir c'est un peu le festival off de
la jeune couture les jeunes stylistes
créateurs de leur mode leurs idées et
leurs griffes les vêtements
d'aujourd'hui en coupe réglée
et pourtant nous ne sommes pas en plein
délire ou en pleine révolution
mais dans le monde créatif des jeunes
cela se passe à hier au salon des jeunes
stylistes vraiment quelques visions des
jeunes stylistes sur le prêt-à-porter
d'aujourd'hui c'est confortable le noir
est très présent cela peut être aussi
plus classique
ils sont 27 jeunes créateurs de la
france entière à être venus présenter
leurs dix plus beaux modèles
le but de ce salon m les jeunes
stylistes et les diffuseurs en contact
une passerelle qui ne se trouvent pas
aussi facilement
moi je pense que c'est un petit peu
comme les métiers du service
c'est un milieu très fermé et seulement
en tant que c'est pas tout à fait normal
si on doit aussi faire avec ça c'est
vrai qu'il faut beaucoup travailler pour
y arriver on a voulu faire une
manifestation qui leur permettra
justement de faciliter leur entrée dans
la vie professionnelle derniers instants
avant le défilé les détails ultime à
régler un peu de trac aussi pourquoi pas
matile le pôle hitano est une varoise de
24 ans elle sort de l'école esmod de
nice une référence chanel pour elle
comme ses vingt six autres collègues ce
salon c'est un lieu d'échangé privilégié
avant de s'installer définitivement à
hyères soient d'hier parce que justement
j'ai envie de faire quelque chose dans
la région il n'y a pas grand chose en
fait tout a vraiment craint qu est ce
que vous êtes venu chercher à ce salon
vous le dirait un petit peu à vos
collègues ça se passe comment exactement
non me mesurer non enfin je pense qu'il
faut se tenir au courant de tout ce qui
se fait donc voir effectivement ce que
les autres font que parent resté enfermé
dans son truc
et puis surtout
prendre des contacts avec des fabricants
ce fait important quand même collection
c'est une collection assez classique
en fait pour des femmes qui sont actifs
dynamiques s'ils pensent ses vêtements
classiques 13 femmes mais quand même
assez sportif je me sois un vêtement
soit pour tous les jours clôture de ce
salon dimanche à l'espace hermès 2 hier
27 jeunes stylistes 27 idée de la mode
d'aujourd'hui par des jeunes de 22 à 29
ans